hi guys I'm here with Deanna dengler and
she is part of the chess and education
conference here at the London chess
classic we're innovative educators talk
about their different projects and kind
of inspire other educators I know you're
doing a lot of work with chess and
refugees right and you gave a
presentation can you tell us about that
yes and then living in I live in Munich
and we have a dare
chess Academy and transformation and we
support refugees with a chest and we
make many projects with the tests in
school with the small children with
disabled children with autism people
with old people and now we find out it
is need to do something for Refugees why
is it important to do chess work with
refugees because when they come to to
some some country like Germany dia alone
they have a trauma they need some help
and they can't speak a language but with
the Tres language you can find friends
you can you can do something for for
your future it happened to me as well
when war started in Boston for Mabus
Libya I play the test tournament and I
couldn't go back home and chess was my
language as a tres which as I worked and
just make for me possibility to find new
friends to find people that they think
the same like me that's why it's for me
very important that we do something for
refugees fantastic well if you want to
find more about that go to the London
Chest and education conference page and
I think there'll be a video of your talk
up eventually so thank you very much
Deanna Dengler working with Ches and
refugees in Germany and talking about it
here in London such an important topic